[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the break room everybody
our nerdy news show that keeps you
updated on what you need to know uh live
from New Rockstar's headquarters here uh
I'm Zach cuddle so I'm thrilled to be
here with you today with my compatriots
Brandon Barrick Jessica Clements and
Tommy bechtold today we're going to be
talking about
so I agree well actually he might have
no he doesn't have a camera before uh
today we're gonna get even more fungi uh
Spider-Man's influence on Quantum Mania
and most importantly we're going to
cover everything that we are excited to
be revealed in 2023. this is we have
this running list of things we're
waiting on and we've created a top 10
list of like things we most and this
isn't like the release of a movie or a
series these are more like trailers
announcements castings these kinds of
things that we don't know when we're
going to get them we know when the
movies are going to come out right but
we do not know when some of these other
things are going to be revealed
announced whatever and we've got a
pretty hot top 10. and I will say this
the number one
it's spicy I don't think you're gonna I
don't it might be controversial long
heated conversation about this also I'm
told that this list operates under Santa
rules and it'll only come true if we're
good oh that looks like we have the list
in a basement somewhere yeah
we've connected all 10 of these things
together
okay if we don't get 300 if we don't get
300 in super chats the list gets the
list okay
um but hey before we get to that we we
do have some fun headlines we want to
cover headlines oh
um first and this is we're really
excited about this because we have loved
loved this show so far hey last of us
got renewed for season two
shocking news
two tests yes
um because you know we're only
two episodes deep into season one
episode
Brandon Jessica and Anna vanston have
been doing an awesome job on the after
show here on the break room every Sunday
evening Eric Voss of course doing the
breakdowns that come out Monday uh we're
we love this show and we're so glad
they're going to give us a second season
when do we think that second season
might come out well I mean there's no
indication that they're already filming
it as far as I know I mean this was one
of those kind of announcements where
like well yeah they're gonna do a season
two because they've already been talking
like well season two will cover the
second game and like all all that stuff
so we're it's kind of like when they
announced oh House of the Dragons
getting a second season it was like
unless it bombed yeah unless like nobody
watched the show and it was a mess and
maybe three horses died during filming
all the luck uh the show was gonna get
canceled but like this didn't happen so
but they are gonna have to wait because
it takes a long time for the mushrooms
to pin a guy up against the law and grow
all over them right wow a long time ago
they gotta wait for these cities to fall
apart that's right but um we already
know that like we're not gonna get House
of the Dragon in 2023 as far as we know
yeah it seems like 2025 I also think
it's like a matter of just like the
production it takes to do House of the
Dragon versus a lot of the CGI that's in
uh the the the last of us so it might
come out quicker than we expect well if
they film on location in your Jersey
there's already everyone has an
infectious disease and most of the
buildings are condemned get out of the
same time and I've been even with their
not crazy CGI shows like succession or
Barry or whatever there's often on HBO
there's an 18 month or two year Gap in
between Seasons unfortunately so we
don't know but hey fingers crossed early
2024 maybe maybe I'll be 53
or or maybe late no yeah that's probably
the earliest we could expect it even
that would be a pretty tight turn
would be so ridiculous because they're
just it's also if they got to keep up
with the games it's like you're going to
be way ahead of the games eventually and
speaking of which uh the second season
is going to kind of cover The Last of Us
Part Two a lot of that game storyline of
kind of mapping the seasons over the um
the show and I think they are Craig
Mason has said they have plans for three
seasons at least Oh I thought I might be
making that up maybe I had plans for
Craig Mason I think this was something
where he was interviewed and he said if
they did a second season they'd have to
do a third season I mean that's a great
thing to say as to the show writer like
well if you give us honestly we'll have
to do five seasons I mean a little
little inside baseball uh when you make
a TV show you get paid extra for the
later Seasons than you do for the first
so of course he wants there to be more
so like friends just was making it oh my
God but it's even it's built in like
even the like you know the lower level
people who aren't even the creators of
the actors they get like a 10 raise
every extra season then it goes or
whatever so Bob's Burgers every season
you got like a lot of money and I was
like oh cool and then they got renewed
every time I've been here for six years
and so far I've gotten a Chili's gift
certificate well we haven't renewed you
Tommy you're just still here what I get
every Monday at 8am I get a phone call
it says you get in here we're killing
you uh you got a chili certificates
can't pay rent with a Chili's gift
certificate I'm sorry just to be clear
it's chill ease the dry ice company
they make dry ice boxer groups
another another headline uh industry
Insider Jeff Snyder of the hot mic
podcast uh hot Mike with Tommy's
codename oh yeah right uh now this is
again this guy uh often has like early
Scoops yeah for the most part he's very
well connected so a lot of these groups
have turned out to be accurate this is a
rumor alert very very roomery but he uh
says that supposedly Ryan Gosling will
somehow be connected to Marvel's
Fantastic Four movie I like that one
he's gonna attend opening night he's got
his ticket I heard he's the
cinematographer I mean will we be mad if
you play like I already catered the
whole thing oh well and it is
interesting now we assume Ryan Gosling's
an actor has not done any directing or
producing me whatever so we assuming
this is a casting thing it's not that
he's going to direct or something I
heard he's reprising his role from first
man he's going to play Neil Armstrong oh
and they're going to be the Fantastic
Force going to space to save Neil
Armstrong
I do Wonder like if he's not gonna be
any of the of the Richards family I mean
like villain he he could either be
doomed as being an inspired Doom I
really don't like the the uh trend of
casting although Ryan Gosling is a tall
a taller man for an actor he's not thick
enough to be thing right oh no no but
we're gonna CGI thing though right yeah
doesn't want to commit to a multivay
film franchise so maybe he does come in
as a villain or I mean it's a sweet gig
if you can get that Josh brolinist
Thanos what if he's Galactus he's
tall but he's also still
tiny to me so I don't want him being I
want Galactus to be the most strongest
person looking because oh so I should
play Galactic yeah hmm
Galactic galactomic I'd only want him to
be like black ass I would only want him
to be Johnny Smith uh yeah well well
we'll see we'll see if that rumor turns
out to be true maybe that that subject
might come back in our uh most
anticipated 2023 things
um there it is there's the list uh the
sad list uh uh bear Breakout
in the cast of the Thunderbolts in an as
of now undisclosed role she was um yes
chef uh you know the besides uh Jeremy
white is who's the other yeah and white
and her we're kind of the two leads the
black girl and big mouth yes yeah he's
taken the spot she also like God I this
is this is me Hollywood talking I've
worked with her so many times before
everything blew up and I was like we
were on the same track and I was like
God I knew I should have done stand-up
comedy but her stand-up's really good
it's so time Jessica if you want to
leave
recently turned 49. yeah and I'm out of
it you've got time you're a young woman
Dangerfield didn't get started until he
was in his 50s it's true
famously get a lot of respect so sorry
no respect um back to her yeah we don't
know who's gonna be playing yeah it'd be
interesting I I was speculating what if
she works in uh valentina's yeah office
I'm sure somebody like that we're
assuming like she's not maybe not might
not be a super powered individual they
might not introduce light well ant woman
which that's fine but like they might
not introduce new super powered
individuals they're trying to pull them
from existing properties right but or
maybe no I don't think her credits have
a lot of action in it like her
physically doing things but I do think
she's very organized from the bear so
maybe the situation of her just being
completely her knife skills are up to
par oh um yes in an interview with sfx
magazine Ant-Man quantumania writer Jeff
lovnes who is getting out there the man
is doing press good for you Jeff uh it
says that the Spider-Man comics helped
influence the tone of Ant-Man 3. it's
interesting you didn't say the Ant-Man
Comics there's lots of those what do you
think might have pulled there from the
Spider-Man comics
I mean there's a family is so important
to the Spider-Man comics right the idea
of loss in family and disappointment and
family I wonder if maybe you know tragic
passing of uh parental figures yeah well
that's something he kind of he kind of
touched it in a quote right he was
mentioning both like what he'd noticed
in the Lord of the Rings franchise and
then in Spider-Man the shifting of tone
from being lighthearted and comedic to
intense apocalyptic Stakes which like
obviously the ambient French has had
lots of lighthearted comedic beats this
will maybe be the first in that
franchise to do a little bit more of the
apocalyptic heavy Stakes right yeah and
you know Scott Lang is like a character
who didn't set out his life to be a hero
and has kind of been gifted this ability
I mean his comes from a soup but still
it was like kind of placed on him and it
seemed by the world is like a hero but
does he feel that way and now that like
everything as you said everything's on
his shoulders like can he handle that I
also wonder I mean it's not directly
from the quote but Spider-Man I feel
like villains in Spider-Man although
they are you know classic Marvel
villains they're often a little funnier
they're often a little quippier can be
goofy the nature of the way it's written
I think is like they usually are like
zinging tit for tats with uh with
Spider-Man so I wonder if you know with
Modoc yes I agree I'm like yes well
thank you thanks so much yeah with Modoc
maybe there might be some more repartee
there back and forth yeah maybe hang
doesn't seem like a real jokester but
maybe Modoc is bringing the Goofs yeah I
think modoc's definitely Bill Murray we
know obviously is going to be delivering
uh Michael Douglas has some chops yeah
we know there'll be some Owen obviously
um he'll go to town with anybody yeah
and okay nope moving on we know he's got
jokes he just said Dave bucks that's
right that's right uh speaking of
Ant-Man the watch quantumania do you
guys notice anything different about me
our first uh quantumania shirt that is
now available for sale or will be within
the next hour or so uh rain Eternal and
it's got this cool stylized Kang kind of
in a kind of in a Jesus Christ pose
really when you think about it we have
an entire line of quantumania shirts
this is the earliest we've ever had a
shirt available for like a Marvel or
Star Wars or anything kind of property
and we did it specifically if you buy it
now or even in the next week you can
have it for the premiere for the movie
you've been wearing it opening night I'm
gonna wear an opening night just that
I'm a Donald Duckett just the shirts
what is this uh Burning Man uh but you
can get excuse me you can get this shirt
and uh there's other cool designs that
are in like a similar kind of stylized
way but like one has uh Ant-Man one has
the WASP there's another her Kang shirt
but as uh this is actually mt's idea and
design to do it as the Vitruvian man
that famous Leonardo da Vinci uh design
but you can get all of these and it's a
little new you can still go to new
rockstarsmerch.com and that works but
we're kind of we've revamped our our
merch website a little bit it's now
called
nerdriot.shop nerd Riot like what you do
when we don't go live right at 3 P.M
nerd Riot no Riot that shop learn right
at dot shop so check that out grab one
of these shirts again grab one in the
next week and you wear to the premiere
and then when you're you know at the AMC
or the Regal Lobby or whatever and you
see somebody across the way it's
snacking on their popcorn and they're
also wearing uh a Kang shirt you'll be
like oh do the Spiderman meme
I won't stay quiet about nerd Riot
thank you
you better go buy it straight at nerd
Riot got shot
oh there he goes I only stay in Hyatt
wearing my nerd Riot dot shop
you know what Tommy I want to deny it
but it's at nerd Riot okay if you see a
plane you should fly it and then go to
nerd Riot dot plane
uh should we go should we begin our our
exciting list yes
all right we all gotta walk down to the
basement so yeah
it's the vein of like you know this is
the beginning of the year Tommy the
camera's not on here the month is almost
over and there's still stuff we're
waiting for uh announcement wise like
things that are gonna happen this year
early next year that we've gotten like
no news on we're pretty excited too we
were kind of talking like do we need a
state of the union what's like the state
of our new nerd Union we started
throwing out the things you're excited
about then we started having arguments
about it so we've got to rank it we
wanted to make a ranking so starting at
number 10 okay this is the thing this is
the 10th oh God someone help him most
excited I will kill this board oh my God
number
secret Invasion releases yes I've been
beating the drum for this so we are
expecting to get somewhere between three
and four Marvel Disney plus Series this
year secret Invasion supposedly the
first then we know we're getting Iron
Heart uh Echo might be delayed we don't
know what if season two maybe X-Men 97
all these things we have no idea when
any of those things are coming out
Marvel is in Disney has not really a
mess you know timeline boards we saw
Comic Con yeah a little bit movies have
release dates but shows do not have
release dates and secret invasion is a a
loose spring
we know the Mandalorian starts in March
but we have no idea when the first
Disney series tell us Disney tell us
yeah oh and real quick when do we think
we might hear that well if they said
Spring right if they if if Kevin feige
follows the Equinox right spring would
begin somewhere around March 21st we
would officially be in Spring
we have the Super Bowl coming up they've
dropped a trailer okay when is the Super
Bowl Tommy the Super Bowl is February
13th thank you Tommy and just sorry
Jessica was shot at the [__] reveal the
next one I don't enjoy it but
um do we think secret invasion in the
Mandalorian might overlap there might be
weeks where both of them are coming out
at the same time I hope so that makes me
a busy boy I hope not because remember
when we had the situation where we were
doing all of the I mean great great for
us great for Content great for everybody
but it was like at one point it felt
really bad being like I'm just gonna
save Miss Marvel for tomorrow and do
Kenobi right now because I love staying
up till 5 a.m you are alive bad batch
runs it has they're only on episode five
five yes it has come out six comes out
there's 16 episodes there's 10 more
weeks 10 more weeks bad batch uh 15 if
the groundhog sees his shadow so that's
definitely going to overlap with
Mandalore but okay
if it developer I guess make it like oh
this comes out Wednesday this comes out
Sunday like those that matches out every
Wednesday so they could do Star Wars
Wednesdays Marvel Thursdays
then in the long run they should do that
we're off track here okay
I'm going okay number nine number nine
yeah number nine why would you go any
other number oh okay we've been talking
about this right we got that great
little animated weird little teaser
we were speculating we think this is
shooting right now we're anticipating
getting this film released next year I
think it's a 2024 release right and so
yeah when when do we think they might
drop that trailer I think we'll get it
this year we have to because we only got
the image right the yeah we got just the
title no we got a photo of him getting
shaved right oh yeah we did get the
photo of him being shaved with this
weird concave chest uh and then yeah the
weird animatic I would think you know
this movie one of an Oscar for watching
Phoenix they could put it out a trailer
out around Oscar season just yeah like
hey remember this oh remember this you
Maniacs yeah and again we were saying
it's not a super CGI heavy thing we
think the last one wasn't so it's not
like even if they're shooting right now
they might have enough footage that they
can slap together a pretty nice teaser
trailer right I'm sure they have it I'm
saying October October oh that late okay
I think that's something uh that will
not be the last time a Warner Brothers
or DC property comes up in this list
a tease Brandon you want to reveal
number eight should he do eight do you
think
are you done
whoa he's only 23. okay Marvel special
this is this is my heart maybe put an S
on it maybe presentation this is my
hobby horse right yes we got there were
rumors about werewolf by night and
Guardians uh holiday special but then
they didn't like officially announce
them to like a month before they came
out and they kind of just dropped out of
the sky out of nowhere now we hope they
do more this year yes but there have not
even been nothing rumors or anything
give us a Captain America Fourth of July
yeah I'm thinking something I think they
have to give us a sandwich either
Memorial job or the summer now if they
were going to do something by Memorial
Day I think we would have heard about it
by now um well what about in the turtles
oh and a way to keep them in the
Zeitgeist tournament like with guardians
right like with guardians they took a
movie that was already shooting and
they're like hey can you take an extra
week and shoot this extra thing so could
we get a Marvel's something oh yeah yeah
because Marvel's you know they've shot
that movie we've seen footage at d23 so
we know it's mostly done yeah yeah if
they were while they were doing that
they put together a little like a summer
vacation Kamala Khan story or something
like that what if we just don't get one
I'd be heartbreaking but they don't do
it as often as we talk about right like
well no they just did two last year and
those are the first ones they've ever
done yeah they did it and then it's like
oh we came up with you great let's take
a break this year we'll do it back in
2024. yeah at least make an announcement
about the next one at some point this
year like they've got to do a Halloween
one got a team I mean hey we know we
know we got blade coming next year I
mean they've got to be thinking are you
ever into like I am Groot as a special
presentation because I was like it's a
series though I thought they didn't put
the thing on the iron group yeah they
didn't have the openings because that's
where I'm like
hit him
oh there it is oh boys do season four
the boys and season four days
before uh we love the boys yes we're
super excited I mean we know they've
shot this season or they're shooting it
we had a big argument about this because
it was like this should be higher
because we [__] love the show but
it's also like we know what we're
getting yeah this this is the ship that
is sailing through the harbor and it's
doing great it's a cruising altitude so
far very minimal turbulence yeah we're
getting gen you know uh took down
homelander said let's Roll uh uh we know
gen V is coming out this year we're
going to talk about it don't worry we'll
have a little break room after show me a
boy's underground wants to bring that
back
yeah give us that trailer give us that
trailer yeah can I be on it yeah when do
we think do and we have no sense they
have not announced so we have to get
through all of gen V is going to come
out right and the boys will be probably
after that at some point yeah we do are
we getting boy season four in 2023 yeah
yeah I think it'll be this time that's
the thing with Amazon too super
Invincible they were pushing the boys
out they're like get it out as soon we
knew we knew when the boys was finishing
up season three airing it they were
showing Carl Urban was on set showing
photos already shooting season because
of covet and stuff they they were like
let's roll right into it because there
was such a delay between two and three
they're like let's get moving it's
actually kind of ridiculous how fast
they're picking up production for it I
was like why are you guys going so fast
just give it a second I mean it's it's
one of Amazon's good things one of the
best projects and it's it's it's always
I mean every season has been more has
built in terms of viewership I also
believe they're filming right now or at
least casting and recording not filming
animating they're making more of the
boys animated stuff because there was a
casting breakdown that I noticed
that don't you drive the son of
translucent and I was like well the only
translucent I know is the guy from uh
the Santa Claus uh murderous Santa Claus
uh violent night the dad in violent
Knight played translucent
I don't know Brandon do you wanna
number six
batteries Batman slate scene okay so now
this is a combo we put a bunch of things
in this thing yeah this is a very long
time when are we gonna get the Penguin
series yes when are we going to get the
next Robert Pattinson Batman is there
going to be any other kind of spin-offs
in that Universe
we can't wait to hear what's next as far
as we know they're not filming on this
right this movie's not going to come out
this year maybe
also for the Batman at the Oscars
cinematography later so beautiful that
was the way they shot that movie I mean
they only got three nominations I would
make an argument now this is not gonna
be a popular opinion especially among
Academy voters Colin Farrell veteran the
Batman than banjo's Adventure
agreed agreed they sleep on them when
they don't know I never gave Leonardo
for the Revenant who should have gotten
the best I agree with that he should
have gotten for The Aviator uh uh who
should have gotten the best supporting
Actron get this freak out of here
guys uh the original was the Nick
Offerman rolling The Last of Us and
headed back out and then Nick hasnikov
for a minute you could have had that
voice yes
um
again this is not the last time we're
going to hear from Warner Brothers in DC
in this town well here real quick
Jessica we're at the halfway before we
reveal our top five and again it is
spicy really good ones in here we're
also going to reveal some kind of
honorable mention ones uh Hey New Year
you've got goals maybe that maybe those
are fitness goals maybe those are like
time management goals whatever it is
factor is hell here to help you achieve
them look at look at cute little Tommy
Boy back there
um same time and energy with factors
ready to eat meals delivered straight to
your door I can vouch I've had some of
these delicious meals delivered straight
to my door they're tasty yeah they are
extremely convenient they are like
they're also like they taste better than
they even have to right I'm always like
oh there's more spice and flavor and
texture in these things than you expect
you're a hungry boy were they filling
did you feel filled up by these these
meals first up I'm a confirmed hungry
boy yeah you are you people know that
about me I'm the exact Charter remember
the Hungry Boys I've seen Zach in a two
pound burrito in under three minutes
exactly lunch yesterday and he was
talking whole time Zach's launches today
two giant like two giants Jessica
so much it was so my my only fans is
just me deboning chickens okay I don't
want to deter from the ad because it is
important but a lot of people don't know
that Zach and I actually were casting a
pilot the Hungry Boys Mysteries the 1999
we were both child actors at that point
and we played the hungry Brothers uh
hippo and hanko hungry and I guess it
was not what you think he was hippo
that's right don't rush to judge me it's
because I was cool yeah
um anyways uh it's because I was a
beatnik the show uh the show lasted 15
minutes before Wired Magazine said no
Herbie wants to be a dentist uh but um
Factor meals now you've heard us talking
about hellofresh before uh it's a hello
fresh owns factor or they're owned by
the same company
and the difference is no no we love them
both the difference is you got to cook
the hello fresh I also enjoy it I love
cooking meals you don't get a cook
Factor they come in the little things
you just microwave them peel that tape
off eat the delicious food and they've
got yeah they've got you know keto vegan
veggie protein they got you know you can
designate your allergens or whatever you
like on there and they got the special
menus just for you each meal has all of
the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long oh you know what
they don't have what's up snakes
you know I've had a handful of factor
meals none of them had snakes I've
opened a competitors ready to eat meal
and it was full of snakes I don't want
to cast this version on the other guys
pre-cooked meals but they're full of
snakes riddled with them and the snakes
weren't even cooked and I do got to say
if you know uh factor factor meals are
tasty enough like you don't have to be
looking to be healthy or lose weight or
anything like that uh they're just great
tasty convenient meals to have in
general if you are if like fitness
health whatever is part of your goals
this year man what a nice way to do it
again every time I read the back label
on these things I'm like this is only
480 calories that didn't taste like you
know a diet meal or anything like that
they're they're delicious I could
picture with my Factor box shows up at
my door and then a few months later I'm
riding on Hagrid's magical motorbike
right at Universal Studios and they're
not making me get off the ride and
saying Hey Big Boy this guy can't hold
those bones
uh if when you use our promo code Tommy
gets one step closer to writing
accurate's magical guys if we if we sell
enough Factor meals they're gonna send
me to Universe
sorry they're gonna send me away from
the universe
but uh Hey support we appreciate them uh
sponsoring the show all week long uh
support us and do yourself a favor head
defectormeels.com break room 60 and use
code break room 60 to get 60 off your
first box that's code breakroom 60 at
factorymeals.com slash break room 60 to
get 60 off your first box that comes
with a bunch of meals again tasty this
is an authentic personal endorsement I'm
giving right now sweet boy verified let
me get back into the discussion I want
to shout out a special super chatter hit
it uh this is this person's first Super
Chat I want to shout out Kentucky junk
oh yeah Kentucky junk said hello from
from the Appalachian Foothills as
Hillbillies in our nerdy news too love
you guys Kentucky Trucking got a lot of
family near Bowling Green yeah uh uh
help them out and you know you know
you don't say please
one person's Kentucky junk is another
man's Kentucky treasure that's right
that's right that's right also thank you
Faith Joyce been listening since
pre-doctor strange too I love you uh
Jamie Riley putting out loving that
they're full of snakes factors are not
full of snakes no snakes no snake three
uh we'll save Ellie up
we got a couple other good ones we're
gonna Circle back to some of these uh
super chats Jessica didn't want to
reveal number five can I say this I've
made a swan since uh Fried Chicken TV
dinner the other day 15 snakes
Jesus Christ what is this prisoners if
you can't fit the right of universal
just don't go Universal yeah I can't fit
the rights of universal either boom what
do we got 20 20 23 Star Wars series
we're talking we're talking Ahsoka Tana
soakers we're talking skeletons yes
we're talking maybe
well we're thinking that's 124th they're
already shooting oh they're shooting I
mean I could see a hot little trailer
before the end of the year to tease us I
mean that that one I'm very excited
about because it is so far away from all
the Star Wars we know uh I don't want to
see a TIE fighter I don't want to see a
stormtrooper what about Tatooine uh
now I will go to Kathleen Kennedy's
house now and say no thank you real
quick uh what's that John
they've wrapped on indoor season two
that could be included
when is Star Wars celebration this year
uh April April in the UK yeah
um could we get that'll be kind of after
or during Mando season three but before
any of these other things could we get
kind of a mega trailer maybe though they
show stuff at Celebration that they do
not that's true put online that's true
uh and you have to read Tommy's
descriptions of it yeah I'll be there in
London I'm just kidding I probably will
uh we should sip them out yeah yeah guys
come on if you wait if you subscribe to
enough factored boxes they'll send me to
London boyv if you got a spare room in
your flat for this mate yeah
all right
we're really enduring ourselves
Star Wars coming in armor elevation
let's have a point in a bit of fish and
chips
was that Drake have over there
we were so close to getting number four
yeah yeah
get it yeah
you could also Loop in
um well actually I know I was about to
teach something but we're going to come
back to it yeah so Loki we think we're
getting this end of summer they haven't
announced the release date
and we know there's a good trailer they
showed it at d23 oh it's a great little
trailer maybe Super Bowl
let's talk about we know we're getting a
fast 10 trailer the week of the Super
Bowl right in the past we've gotten
great kind of Disney Plus
trailers right uh there we could get
like all these series we're hoping for a
little secret Invasion a little bit of
uh Loki maybe some like Iron Heart iron
Hearts yeah stuff yes um are there any
other big films we think we might get at
The Flash trailer Flash trailer oh it
was kind of a fake one circulating yeah
we almost got fooled by rumorinos out
there that maybe another Guardians
trailer no I don't know do we get it
audience is going to give us another
trailer for sure but I don't know if
that's Super Bowl just before
quantumania I don't know may may oh no
they may want to wait until after
quantumania like to really press that
what about uh Indiana Jones full trailer
a new a new Indiana Jones trailer a
Marvel's trailer Marvel oh it's so early
for the marbles but maybe maybe we're
gonna get like those ah which I I don't
like this this is just me like the
Ant-Man Heineken commercial yeah like
we're gonna get those we're definitely
Turbo Tax ant-man's involved in yeah but
just make one of those Capital One
commercials make him Nick Fury not
Samuel Jackson that's what I'm saying
Capital One Cinematic Universe is so
dense I mean that would be a great
secret Invasion trailer if it starts
it's got like one commercial and then
like he gets stabbed and it turns out
it's like you thought you were watching
I mean it's the tight ads all over again
but like was it wonder man that's also
the actor yeah his introdu introduction
is a commercial trailer oh that's a
great idea do a commercial and you have
no idea it's for Wonder Man and then
when Wonder Man eventually comes out you
see them filming that commercial wait
isn't that isn't that at the Geico guy
the gecko
no come on man you're more respectful
than that Gekko has a name you like
Gekko unfortunately before you do three
before I know we keep cutting them off
no that's fine before we get to our top
three I'm glad I just want to say I'm
glad Tommy's jokes he just said got cut
off by a crosstalk it's uh that was a
service to humanity was it a bad joke
you want to repeat it no no before we
get to our top three okay uh we gotta
get to some honorable mentions yes uh
thank you super chatter and Jacob Smith
hello from Australia
so like I said we had a lot of arguments
around here about what should be in the
top 10 we only had 10 spots what would
it give me we had to cut some stuff
these are some honorable mentions that
we cut from the list okay ironheart and
Covenant of chaos now obviously coming
to chaos they're just shooting it right
now that might be too early we know they
were they were filming during d23 or
they had been done some filming we saw a
little footage so we could get that Iron
Heart trailer
um a couple big Marvel movies we maybe
know the main cast but like we don't
know who's gonna play the villain or
what the villain's gonna be in Deadpool
who the villain might be or who's
playing it in Blade yeah right those are
2024 movies but it would be cool to know
that kind of stuff the villain from uh
the original blade just came out yeah I
was like oh shut your mouth he's out
there talking about today we're all
adults
like Marvel movies yeah he says all
Marvel movies are worse than blade
that's what he says oh cool well I was
like this is the only one I like and
then kind of some like uh some other
properties that we don't know we know
they're working on another season but we
don't know when we might get it or get a
trailer stranger fire stranger things
season five yeah the final season uh we
don't know when that's coming out or if
we don't know when we're going to get it
but if we get a trailer for their side
project because aren't the upside down
doing things that are kind of stranger
things adjacent right Stephen King
adaptation is that what that Endeavors
yeah we gotta we gotta hear from uh uh
rafita
right now
also wait didn't they announce that the
Geico Gecko is going to be one of the
villains no I don't think so let's show
some results
I don't know also we don't have uh
release dates or any other information
about Peacemaker season two yeah I just
know it's alive yeah we hope so they
haven't I don't think they've started
shooting anything or anything like that
but um uh this is a personal favorite of
this staff White Lotus season three
locations where's it gonna be Thailand
Switzerland I thought they said Mike
White's like in Thailand you said Asia I
thought you said Asia
why those I saw this on a tick tock that
people were talking about and I was like
oh I guess they got out and then we
never talked about it here so I assumed
it was maybe I said we are the right
you're the Finger Lakes yes
White Lotus cats
Okefenokee Swamp yeah all the all the
world's most beautiful locations uh
Ontario my my personal most anticipated
uh thing that I'm personally looking
forward to doing two trailer oh yeah the
spice must flow now that movie is not
coming out for a while so I don't know
when we'll I don't think they've started
shooting that yet either but I'm very
excited for it now we were saying this
is this is a very uh Advanced thing but
like announcing what's the next
live-action Spider-Man movie we're gonna
get yes yeah we were kind of talking
about that because we don't I don't
think we'll see any new Spider-Man movie
before Secret Wars wow I think we'll see
Spider-Man in Marvel stuff but I don't
think there will be a standalone
Spiderman movie
let that fly and so that would put it at
2026 yeah oh that's a long time for Sony
to wait to make that money okay two
things two things they still we still
have across the spider verse the anime
series sure which I know yes
about Ziggy Comics is my friends 3D or
nothing did you see the Tom Holland
mentioned which oh God please don't do
this he he's interested in being in
Euphoria
I don't hang out that'll break up your
relationship
always good to hear Hey welcome to
Friday yes uh yeah real quick before we
get to the top three here uh shout out
to uh Elia fulmano uh okay and then I'm
not going to read your thing because
again they might spoil one of the things
we're about to say shout out paint to
minty uh Jacob Smith hello from oh you
already called him out uh Jenny Davis
wants that King gang T-shirt oh hey
nerdriot.com my friend
um dot shop dot shop thank you Jessica
keeping me honest party don't stop it
right at the shop our friend Christian
unpronounceable uh dropping elbows from
Canada in there thank you Corey
kendrilli xenix with a a pound symbol
before your super chat so I assume
you're coming from maybe from the UK
group happy Friday yeah beautiful house
not feeling great today but always bring
a smile under me face to see you guys
wow I hope you feel better yeah I feel
better and then uh thank you Perry
Clemens happy Friday back to you
beautiful person okay the horses go clap
clap nerd Riot dot shot let's get to
this top three it's a good time here we
go here we go yeah
it's time guys we've taken it to the TV
we've heard your please it's always
going to crinkle paper when you're
talking we've listened me Kathy falone's
we've been listening we get it we we
perfected the TV game okay we gave you
Mando we did book above economic uh
sandor
it's time to get back up on the Silver
Screen here we go announce a film give
us is it Phil isn't Tiger
they conducted this like writer's room
last year where they had a bunch of
smart people Lindelof was there leading
it supposedly and supposedly they they
kind of broke some stories for films and
like here's the thing they've had a lot
of success at the Disney plus series
Star Wars movies make a billion dollars
it's time to get back let's get one in
the theater I actually heard that the
The Next Star Wars film was
Tatooine Origins oh the of the planet
yeah it's just how the planet was
created it was covered in water at some
point of course
um okay let's do the time well then they
dried it you do number two number two
yeah number two okay
number two this is a big one now
see what you think
James Gunners because he said January
and we're almost in February we have
very few days left James we literally
have like four days literally we've been
refreshing James Gunn's Twitter feed
every day multiple times I'm making us
come in on the weekend just in case this
news stops we're like doctors for
surgery because that's important we're
just ready we're on
um so James gotten just as a refresher
right James Gunn and Peter Safran went
into a cabin in the woods or whatever
watch that watch that scary movie uh
with uh Chris Hemsworth but then they
came up with supposedly a 10-year plan
for DC that they pitched to evil villain
David zazlov uh and he said cancel three
more shoes every time you [__] me a
film I take away six uh relax me delete
these animated shows from HBO remove No
Reservations from HBO Max I mean in the
fact that most people cannot name a
single Studio executive but everybody
knows David zazoff and hates his guts um
but supposedly they came up with this
10-year plan they pitch into Dave
Pizzazz live they've worked through
something maybe there's some compromises
some changes he's ready to reveal at
least the first couple movies like the
first three years we'd hear him first
which that might only be four movies
five movies right we don't know we think
a Comic-Con they're gonna they're gonna
swing for the fences and really release
a big slate so I would expect it so what
we're anticipating right is before the
end of January if he's a man of his word
which is just the next couple days he'll
at least give us some titles maybe some
general release dates then what do you
think happens at Comic I think at Comic
Con they do what Marvel did this year
and they're like we're ready to show you
the next and we're getting actors
directors maybe other Farther Along
movies and Series yeah yeah you know if
you guys think that James Gunn has been
suspiciously quiet
head on over to nerd right good job done
Tommy's doing a good job with King gang
for the brand gang gang well let me go
ahead and uh yeah we're excited for
James Gunn it's coming out soon but
there's something we're most excited
yeah give him number one okay I told you
it was spicy folks number one feel free
to add me
feel free to add me on snap oh premium
give a number one it's the Barbie
released that's right head on over to
The Pink Carpet
yeah we're excited for the okay it's not
really yet okay
[Applause]
this is a Fantastic Four cat yeah okay
yeah I mean forecast is calling for oh
storms oh we've been doing the
characters how long have people been
speculating on this I mean who is this
at this point ever since they put it
back four right and yeah for a long time
they've been talking about it and then a
d23 there was this like buzz in the room
where it was like okay they said at
Comic-Con they're gonna do a Fantastic
Four movie they didn't say any cast we
think we're gonna hear it now they put
it up for a second uh shacklin was like
sitting out in the crowd and they're
like he's gonna direct it Frankie had
everyone else come up by saying check it
was like in the crowd it was like stay
there he's directing it uh and then they
were like moving on and everyone was
like what what what what what so it's
been people want to know and we put this
at number one because we were all kind
of like is this the number one
anticipated thing I think this is the
next movie that is not introducing new
characters introducing characters that
we haven't seen in the MCU but have been
tried to be franchised twice already
maybe three times already if you count
Roger Corman yeah like this is and these
are characters that everyone knows yeah
this is Marvel's first family they're
gonna be a big Cornerstone probably of
the future of the MCU I mean this has
been going on for so long I believe
Chaplin was rumored to be Doom Charlie
Chaplin rumored to be doing and Morgan
Fairchild was going to be Sue storm no
way yeah no wow no it was actually
you're evil twin Morgan unfair
same first name different last name okay
um yeah I mean we're very excited also
like when when's this this move this is
a 2025 movie 2026. it's just before Kang
Dynasty 20 there it is thank you John 20
25. 20 25. Valentine's Day so it's like
yours they also but like they've gotta
get into production pretty soon these
movies take a long time to finish in
post-production and everything like that
right so like they might what what do
you think are the odds this movie has
already been cast and the big four has
already been picked I think they haven't
announced I think that's high I think
they've casted Reed
but I still think it's so hard to cast
all four and it's so many different
people that are probably being looked at
that they're like this is taking forever
The Rock has to sign his contract to
play Ben Grimm there was that instance
too of you know uh Daniel Craig was
going to be Baldur the brave he I don't
know if he ever shot anything but yeah
had conversations and it was going to
happen we we saw like the photo of like
a stunt double like playing him on like
the green screen or whatever yeah uh but
like that never leaked that it was never
announced it was like kept secret he
never talked about so it's like there
could be some a couple people have
already been cash floating around there
were rumors that they had no idea who
was gonna they still as of like two
months ago they had no idea but I don't
know they don't have a script yet they
don't know like maybe the take maybe
they have a general idea of the take
like is it a younger Fantastic Four is
it an older right because you've got to
be age-appropriate if you cast a a um
John Krasinski right Richards well then
sue storm needs to be close to that age
you can't then unless he's a hound dog
you know what I mean unless she's
younger
you know he has an intern you know she's
she's old enough to get married no no
you know close the blinds you know what
was the blinds not the doors
so he doesn't need ask her to do any of
those things he could do it himself wow
wow we got a huge package and the Box
just came from the mail uh
uh throw in the chat do you agree with
our top 10 specifically that top three
would you have picked those as the top
three most anticipated announcements for
2023 and particularly that number one do
you think that's a bigger deal than the
DCU slate I gotta say you Capri to they
showed me up okay number one should have
been the Jubilee truth you're exactly
right no I didn't put on this board
because I know it's happening I'm not
you know wrong it doesn't have to happen
we will get the Jubilee Trilogy
announcement we just kind of looks like
we just got really angry at Princess
Peach and master up in our hands no only
to you it's only to you
confused why won't you Bumble me one of
those super Chatters had uh a fan
casting for uh
yeah I think it was uh uh what's his
name from the Halo Pablo Schreiber from
the HALO Series Richards oh yeah leave
schreiber's brother I also say if you've
watched a little Indie movie after sun
or maybe you enjoyed last year's a lost
daughter or the series uh normal people
either is read or is Johnny I don't know
he's a talented actor well as either I
haven't heard his American accent so
he's an Irish actor I don't know if he
can do a solid American accent but I
really I really like to see Michelle
then I want to see Machine Gun Kelly get
out of here Megan Fox's Sue machine gun
I will say Timothy chalamet has yet to
do a superhero movie channel foreign
[Music]
like not listening to Authority and I
want like Ben and her brother to be
older and wiser and trying to be like no
you can't be doing this Weird Science
[__] I mean I'm like mix up the first
family don't make them all the same age
make them like have different
motivations like stream 23 read 25
Johnny 60
[Music]
my son had cancer from what
I like the idea of them doing a little
gender swap here to make a zoo storm
have Reid Richard's powers and read
Richard that is that is wild Brandon
that's heretical in some circles
speaking of storms Erin storm I'm sure a
close blood relative of Sue storms
saying happy Friday happy Friday to you
from Canada Aaron storm yes
um big head gang t-shirts Yuka I'll tell
you when when the big head hats sell out
that's right first we need a big head
hat then we get a big head shirt it's
only become an extra smaller
uh we ran a poll what is your most
anticipated announcement leading the way
Loki season two trailer I mean I think
that's a guaranteed win so it's like
we're all anticipating that we're all
excited it's our first uh Marvel series
sequel I'm surprised DCU slate only made
it third 17
uh behind Loki season two is full screen
well I don't blame people you know it's
until that DCU slate drops and we can
feel confident about it it's it's okay
to feel I don't know what's happening it
hasn't been great uh I would like it to
be better well and again maybe the Slate
drops maybe there's something bigger
Comic Con that gets the hype train going
I can't wait for the con Comic-Con the
four of us side by side holding hands
will we have a party there maybe if you
want to see a new rock stars party at
Comic-Con specifically the break room
yeah tweet at us throw out a couple
quick plugs a again reminder nerd Riot
dot shop for the cool uh quantumania
collection in two I want to shout out
our friends at crane brewing in Kansas
City uh Kansas who sent us uh some fun
beers check them out if you're if you're
in the Kansas City area uh and three
we're making plans this year we've
talked about this before we're gonna be
at WonderCon and Anna that's right mark
your calendar that's right we're gonna
be in San Diego Comic-Con hopefully in
May around the area I'm in the parking
lot uh selling stuff out of Tommy's
trunk uh Tommy in the back of his car
tell me you're gonna be an event next
month yes Eric and I will both be at
kybercon sorry let me say that again
John edit this afternoon Eric and I are
going to be at kybercon uh on February
11th or 12th February 12th I think
whatever the day before the Super Bowl
is Saturday it's in uh California San
Francisco San Francisco area I believe
uh Eric and I'll be doing a panel and
we'll be taking pictures and you know
crying me out back and maybe I'll sell
you a little weed
I'm just kidding oh my God
uh thank you all you know it was the
real bouquet you are yeah uh thank you
all for watching the show all week if
you're watching today everybody in the
Super Chat everybody in the chat we
appreciate you we know you're as excited
for all of these things as we are uh and
whenever we do get these announcements
We're not scheduled to have a break room
on Monday remember our Monday break
rooms are now Sunday evening
Last of Us after show if you're watching
Last of Us Again started again catch up
get on there I'm there Jessica's there
and Advance is there very good all right
I'm watching yeah I watch it like a hawk
and then I sleep 23 straight hours into
Monday now if if DCU slate news drops
over the weekend I don't know what's
gonna happen but if it happens Monday
we'll go live on Monday I'll rise up
like Dragon we're ready
okay we've got to put time into sleep
yeah
and by the way chat bouquet like any
good bouquet you get tossed in the trash
as soon as we're done with you have a
great weekend everybody thanks everybody
[Music]
foreign